i heard you talking somewhere in there
how your height difference makes those
stunts more complicated thank you graeme
i didn't say it didn't destroy it
now that is a good story it's a story
well you see there's there's a
particular stun there i don't know if
it's in this but there's a you know he
spider-man swings us on top of a bridge
and he places me there and that's the
bridge yeah that's the bridge we
eventually jump off that i was screaming
yeah um
so
he's supposed to gently you know rest mj
on the bridge and walk away from her
it because of our height difference i
obviously if we're on the same like
point
were attached i would land before him
because my feet obviously hit the ground
before he does
so
what would happen
there's like it's called a bottom mark
isn't it and the bottom mark is to
basically it's a thing that they do in
stunts that is basically designed to
stop you shattering your kneecaps so
zendaya would land and i'm the superhero
i'm supposed to look cool
and she would land and then i would sort
of land like this and my feet would
swing from underneath me and then she
would catch me
[Laughter]
you're actually very very lovely about
you were like oh my gosh thank
you it's so nice to be caught for a
change
[Music]